[Music]
so this this hand is this reconciliation
of these they're not pulling earth I'm
not turning it
[Music]
here's her force I reconcile that one by
going slide the head of it and lifting
and we're testing it for life so her
arms coming in I'm going to let her push
me as I'm neither pushing against her
nor fully nor my head in her definitely
not behind the push
so we time I have to move back to where
I can feel the hand is light okay that's
the opening so I mean just demonstrating
the physics here the hard part is
neither stopping or pulling when to
allow her and I to be one force then I
controlling it
so Mike you might find it easier stand
Nate because you can move to where he
wants this very heavy there so that's
not it
that's where they can lift so our energy
on the front is coming in once it gets
light it's stuck to me and I make it go
around the rest of her inertial top on
her
Jori upper bolt so whoa no you can't go
keep it going could you small move it
it's all you can play with the time and
spin me see how heavy that way so I was
to absorb it
[Music]